This new generation of personal watercraft is
something entirely different.
It does more than skim the surface.
This watercraft dives under water and can
remain submerged at a depth of three feet or
more for up to a minute.
It also leaps into the air and rolls with
the waves.
This watercraft is painted to look like a
vintage fighter jet, and it rolls and dives
like one in the water.
A worker sprays a gel coat into a mold for
the main body.
This gel will become the shiny surface of
the completed fiberglass part.
Once the gel coat has hardened, a worker
brushes a vinyl ester resin onto it.
This resin is known for its water
resistance.
He switches from a brush to a roller as he
generously applies the resin to the hardened
gel coat. The crew, then drapes what's
called chopped strand mat over the mold.
This fabric is made of long strands of
fiberglass.
The binder in it dissolves on contact with
the resin, causing the fabric to soften to
the contours of the mold.
After trimming the excess material, the crew
completely saturates the strand mat with more
resin. Rolling it on firmly gets rid of air
bubbles.
The top half of the main body mold has been
lined the same way.
They now bolt a dorsal fin mold to the back
on the top half of the mold.
The crew now joins the two halves of the
mold.
As a crane lowers the top to the bottom,
workers ensure they line up perfectly and
they lock these two main molds together with
bolts.
A worker enters through the cockpit opening
to roll on more resin.
Meanwhile, another member of the crew pulls
two sheets of fiberglass fabric onto a
cutting machine. The top fabric is a strong,
tightly woven fiberglass, and the bottom one
is the chopped strand mat.
Automated blades cut the fiberglass to
various shapes and dimensions, each one
designed for a different part of the diving
vessel Mold.
These large rectangles will be used to mold
the sides of the watercraft.
After folding up the pieces, the worker
hands them over to the fiberglass technician.
The technician has just an hour to apply the
fiberglass before the recently applied resin
starts to harden.
He builds up eight layers and completely
saturates each one with more resin.
While the thicker fiberglass material
provides strength, the thinner chopped strand
mat aids adhesion and helps the fabrics
conform to the mold.
After a three hour cure, workers have a
solid, seamless fuselage.
The crane lifts the fuselage out of the mold
and moves it onto a dolly where it will stay
while the team works on the other parts of
the watercraft.
The cone shaped front bumper is next.
The worker uses only three layers of
fiberglass to make it because this bumper is
meant to collapse in the event of a
collision.
For that reason, the part is also known as
the vessel's sacrificial nose.
At another station, crew members lined fin
shaped molds with fiberglass and then pour
liquefied plastic into the cavity.
Once cured, the plastic will anchor the top
of a steel wing shaft in the fin.
A worker presses the shaft into the
liquefied plastic with the end protruding
from the fin. A second mold also lined with
fiberglass and filled with a plastic core,
goes on top.
The team bolts it together and leaves the
part to cure.
The Fins will ultimately be supported by a
triangular scaffold made of aluminum square
tubing. The worker clamps the scaffold
framework to a work table to stabilize the
framework as he welds it together.
He then welds the scaffold tower to the
base.
The worker drills holes for the bushings
that will be used to attach the fins to the
scaffold. Stay tuned for more as the team
prepares this personal diving watercraft for
its maiden voyage.
This personal watercraft leaps, dives and
barrel rolls with the waves, but it doesn't
capsize. It's been engineered to return to
an upright position in the water.
And when it comes to the fun factor, this
diving watercraft leaves other recreational
boats in its wake.
To make the diving Watercrafts passenger
cabin, a worker sprays a gel coat onto a form
and covers it with fiberglass.
A computer driven router then carves into
marine grade plywood to produce structural
backing for the sides of the cockpit.
A worker slathers adhesive putty onto the
plywood part and applies more adhesive to the
fiberglass cockpit.
He presses the plywood to the glued areas of
the cockpit and brushes resin onto the front
of the plywood. After cutting the cockpit
section in two, the crew glues the parts to
the inside of the fuselage.
The fabricating team applies adhesive putty
to the cone shaped bumper known as the
sacrificial nose.
They slide it onto the front of the fuselage
and then screw the bumper in place
temporarily while the adhesive sets.
Another worker sans all the fiberglass parts
of the watercraft to remove bumps and
blemishes. This piece is the engine hatch.
The team bolts the aluminum scaffold to the
floor of the fuselage.
This is a test fit to confirm that the
dimensions are exactly right.
As they install the scaffold, they use dummy
wing shafts to correctly position it within
the vessel. They confirm that the dimensions
are right and that the scaffold sits plumb to
the base of the watercraft.
The next team inserts the hatch frame in the
rim around the cockpit.
They'll bond the frame in place later with a
liquid plastic and adhesive putty.
After priming the sanded surface of the
watercraft, team members lowered the 300
horsepower engine into the hatch.
This is a dry fit to confirm everything
lines up correctly.
They will eventually remove the engine for
the final paint and artwork.
As the dry fit continues, they connect the
air tubes to the snorkel fins that deliver
air to the engine.
The engine hatch has by now also been primed
and they fit it to the diving Watercrafts
main body. The crew verifies that the hatch
sits flush with the rest of the fuselage.
A worker installs the exhaust outlet into
the hull at the rear of the watercraft.
Crew members slide elevator fins into
bushings at the back.
These fins will control the pitch axis of
the watercraft.
Next, they install the jet propulsion
system.
Back to the cockpit.
The crew bolts the control pedals to the
floor and run cables to the jet propulsion
unit. The elevator fins and the steering
system.
They reinstall the dive fin scaffold which
has been powder coated in a yellow colour.
The crew connects the defense to the
scaffold.
They situate the control panel just above
the control pedals.
They run a metal linkage from the dive fins
to a control stick.
They then test the control stick and confirm
it moves the dive planes easily and
correctly. Bucket seats made of lightweight
carbon fiber.
Minimize the load for added speed.
They took a rubber gasket into the framework
for the clear canopy that will surround the
occupants. They add a bead of sealant where
the gasket meets to the window frame.
The vessel canopy is made of thick aircraft
grade acrylic.
It's been tinted to repel the sun's rays and
keep the temperature cooler in the cockpit.